tout Paris bruit de vos exploits on dit
que vous êtes un super coup est-ce que
c'est vrai Francis Huster ouais
alors maintenant pour vous réconforter
un petit peu Francis Huster après tous
ces tous ces problèmes que vous avez eu
mais enfin ça va parce que la peste qui
commence et ça on sait que je vous faire
une interview serpent
[Applaudissements]
dans la bouche pas pendant le jingle
vous êtes sans doute Francis Huster l'un
des meilleurs acteurs de votre
génération
des acteurs comme vous il y en a un par
siècle
qui aujourd'hui pourrait réellement
prétendre à votre succession je fais
comme si j'avais pas entendu mais je
pense que dans le style de d'emploi
toreton
qui est un peu la merde et puis Samuel
Labarthe
peut me permettre de vous dire il est
moins beau que vous
bien alors vous effectuez un parcours
sans faute on vient de le voir pour la
rentrée 2001 vous nous avez prévu quoi
en septembre prochain pour la rentrée
2001 peut-être
bon genre tu apprends encore le clou
avec un spectacle je rêve depuis
longtemps et dit que ça c'est la vérité
j'ai eu ton arrête pas de le dire de
faire certains la même chose tous les
deux ensemble alors si voilà si jamais
il y a un problème
on réfléchir on réfléchir pensez sur
Terre vous êtes conscient de votre
charisme de votre charme fou marée va
que pour son charme fou je les trouve
tellement beau Christiane Réali est
magnifique et tous les deux quand je
suis restée encore à Terre Indigo que
j'ai adoré et donc je suis amoureux vous
êtes amoureuse du couple vous non je les
trouve beau
aujourd'hui [__] c'est votre regard
est assez envoûtant vous le savez ça
est-ce que vous en servez sur les gens
est-ce que par exemple vous utilisez ce
pouvoir de séduction que vous avez sur
les gens non jamais
qu'il suffirait que vous regardiez les
gens avec ses yeux comme ça que je ferme
un peu plus ma gueule vous êtes
incroyablement sexy Francis Huster
comment est-ce que vous résistez aux
sollicitations féminine comment est-ce
que vous faites quand il y a une
imaginez bon on n'est pas à la télé vous
rencontrez Mareva dans un dans une
soirée elle se jette sur vous elle vous
fait comprendre que bon voilà comment
vous faites pour résister qu'est-ce que
vous faites à ce moment-là vous avez une
gousse d'ail dans la poche un chapelet
je pensais à cristiana c'est la chance
de ma vie
c'est vrai
comment vous faites vous
imaginez que vous la rencontrez dans une
boîte de nuit elle est folle amoureuse
de vous
dites-moi Francis Huster on continue
l'interdiction pompe
c'est la star internationale
il sait bien quand on est star
international
tout Paris tout Paris bruit de vos
exploits on dit que vous êtes un super
coup est-ce que c'est vrai Francis
Huster ouais
je pense à cristiana
vous êtes le plus heureux des hommes non
oui c'est vrai vous avez pas de problème
dans la vie non aucun problème donc
cette histoire de Mirebeau c'est pas
c'est pas un souci
c'est vrai je me sens grandi de défendre
Mirebeau il faut mais bon quelqu'un
réussira là où j'ai échoué mais vraiment
couteau dans la plaie mais vous êtes sûr
que c'est aussi bien que ça mirbo si si
c'est fantastique
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu